welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and is the Fantastic Four for
Marvel Studios cast we may have just
gotten our first legitimate piece of
casting news as several outlets are
reporting that Pedro Pascal is close to
signing on as Reed Richards as of this
taping but who will make up the rest of
the team and what villain will Marvel
finally choose to fight against their
first family this is the sneak peek
where we take the temperature of
whatever we are watching or looking
forward to as we head into the next
whatever era of our lives in nerdom
joining me once again on this episode
the Sue to my Johnny it's mod Garrett
it'd be so much funnier if you cut to me
and there was no one in the seat and
then I just appeared but no we blew that
one we we yep that's why people were I'm
shielding I'm shielding
yes all right uh mod let's start off
with the almost casting news reported by
deadline earlier this week according to
unnamed sources Pedra Pascal is in talks
to play Reed Richards in Marvel's
upcoming fantastic for a movie coming in
2025 directed by Matt shackman deadline
reports that the deal is quote far from
done and Marvel of course had no comment
but all of this may come down just to
scheduling Pascal already has a busy
year in 2024 it was also reported this
week that The Last of Us season two is
going to start production in January
January 7th in Vancouver he's also in
Gladiator 2 which began filming in
Morocco last summer but that had to Halt
production once strikes began Pascal is
also slated to be in Zack Ker's next
film weapons which will also shoot in
2024 shackman told collider back in
October that fantastic for will begin
shooting sometime in 2024 the film is
slated to release May 2nd 2025 but that
date you know is still probably you know
up in the air happen yeah um so what do
we think about Pedra Pascal uh adding to
the MCU his nerd fandom trophy room
because he's already got Star Wars Game
of Thrones the dceu because he was in
Wonder Woman 84 and The Last of Us in
that collection is this really the best
use of this talented actor for Marvel
Studios look hands down I love Pedro
Pascal I think he's fantastic I've loved
him in all of these properties I think
his um hot hot hot scale is on the rise
with the strikes if there have been this
many delays with shooting and he's
already locked on to sign those
contracts signed he's committed he
doesn't have the luxury of saying no or
like moving on from that he's going to
have to balance it and when they dictate
the shoot he almost has to say yes to
that um I think that there are a number
of um castings out there uh I don't
think that this is a done deal just yet
although usually a leak like this
doesn't happen unless it's a sure thing
I actually think that a dynamic is more
important here so you could be like yeah
we got Pedro Pascal but if you don't
have the right sue the right Johnny you
know the right thing then it's like it's
it's not going to be a coherence I mean
if if we could learn anything from
Jessica Alber as Sue
storm just because they're hot right now
doesn't mean they're going to fit in
with everything um in saying that though
I actually don't want Pedro Pascal as
Reed Richards you don't I don't I I know
that we had John krinski in that blink
uh and you misit moment but there's just
something about seeing him suited up
that I really liked and that rumor had
been going around for so long and having
Emily his wife as Sue storm having that
kind of chemistry my heart kind of like
latched on to that in a bit so I feel
like it's a bit of a curve ball to try
and like unse those two um as Mr and Mrs
Richard
but I don't hate it so it's not a bad
thing yeah I I get that I I loved the
idea of krinski and um Emily Blunt in
the role I also know how difficult it is
to be part of the Marvel franchise and I
don't want to put any married couple
even especially a healthy married couple
through that ringer um because it it can
be a nightmare it can honestly be a
nightmare to have to work on these
movies and go on a publicity tour it's a
lot they got a family you know um that
said um I think Pedra Pascal yes he is
with between the last of us and the
Mandalorian kind of like the It actor
but I don't think it's been of the
moment I think since he appeared as over
in Tyrell in Game of Thrones 10 years
ago he's kind of been the guy of the
decade like was that 10 years ago it it
was so long ago and a chemistry test
yeah I agree with you mod that that is
most important yes uh his chemistry with
Sue storm with Ben Grim with Johnny
Storm so important um and so I would I'm
curious to learn later what the
chemistry tests if they are doing any uh
but what he has proven Pedra Pascal as a
performer is that he can have chemistry
with anybody uh he can have flirty
chemistry with basically everyone in
season four of Game of Thrones he can
have uh chemistry with Bella Ramsey with
a with a kid he can have chemistry with
a puppet through a Mas chemistry acting
chemistry to clarify yeah acting oh yeah
just yeah acting chemistry I'm sorry if
that wasn't clear yeah it well started
with Game of Thrones where it was like
real sexy chemistry but yeah just a
connection on screen that feels like a
humanistic thing so that they're not
just emoting to the camera but they're
emoting to their scene partner uh and I
think he can pull that off I think what
Marvel Studios is probably looking at
right now is a a star who's gonna give
them bang for their buck and he did not
okay don't over don't mince words what
I'm saying from with bang for their Buck
what I'm saying is that this guy um is a
star and he's a known quantity and I
think Marvel has
had they've had some bad luck but also
probably just some Misfortune uh with
with chat with casting newcomers right
uh and they put they heavily invested in
Chadwick Boseman I'm not saying Chadwick
Boseman had to disclose his diagnosis to
them but I know there's probably someone
at Marvel Studios is like damn it you
know we really really wanted him to be
the star of our universe I think it's
such a big ask to say hey we when you
sign this contract we kind of own you
for the next 10 years minimum you know
anything can happen in that time I think
a bigger catastrophe was Ezra Miller uh
Ezra Miller you know where it's like
we're going to make you the face of the
next phase of superheroes um The Flash
is such an important character to so
many people and he just kind of a little
bit Reckless um with his reputation with
his actions and it's like yes when you
when and I guess the pressure of like
you know when you have that um amount of
pressure being put on you you know I
think you've got some actors that handle
it incredibly well like Chris Evans who
really maintained sort of um what the
Integrity of Captain America on and off
screen but then you know that's when
that's when things get a bit murky and I
think Pedro Pascal's kind of proven
himself as a stable actor agreed yeah
and I want to make something clear this
is not me like endorsing Marvel's way of
doing it because I think they are
honestly reverting to the original
Studio method of signing almost lifetime
contracts with actors and I think
there's something kind of messed up
about that where they just own people
forever it worked with Robert dowy Jr
because he was getting his end of it if
you read that MCU book man that guy was
making tens of millions of dollars by
like the third role that he which is so
funny because that first movie really
resurrected his career it really did it
really did and and I wish Marvel I think
Marvel felt like well if we could work
with Robert Downey Jr despite all of his
legal troubles before we can work with
people who don't have perfect records
but it's different it 2006 was one year
2023 is a different year and just the
world is different we expect different
things from our actors and it uh it's
precarious now to get to keep with that
business model of once you cast a role
they stay that role for the next decade
like like if they had an attitude of
like okay well you get we'll sign you
for one movie and then we'll recast you
if we have to because we're in a
Multiverse Saga you know like they are
so bent on sticking this continuity of
like one and I think honestly it's toys
right it's because once they make a toy
they want the likeness to look like that
character for the next 10 years how many
Spider-Man have we had how many Batman
have we had you know so there is you
you'll get like a Trilogy you'll get an
arc and then it's like if that story
Works they can keep telling it as many
times as want to tell it um I I actually
think that when you have someone like
Leonardo DiCaprio famously tell Timothy
sham uh shalam sorry um don't don't do a
superhero movie you know I think that's
when the reputation is kind of going it
was really good way back when now it's
not funny scallet Johansson has sued
Marvel you know because of discrepancies
and pays like it's get it's getting a
bit fickle and o i is is it's yeah I
think that's what's shaping this Pedro
Pascal approach is like he's worked in
uh the industry in high-profile starring
roles for a long time now and I don't
think they have to worry about that I
mean if you you watch a guy like Comic
Con or Star Wars celebration he's happy
to be there yeah he is he's such a team
player and I think that's what they
that's what they need right now there's
so few like I mean this is my industry
right I meet celebrities and interview
them all the time so I get this version
of them there are so few still that love
what they do Jack Black's one of them
Tom crew surprisingly one of them this
guy knows the business and is just such
a support of film making that like he
shows up he goes above and beyond that's
why he's doing his own stunts and like
testing the limit each time but to get
someone like that someone who's proven
themselves and I think you're right
Pedro is one of those people yeah it's
an interesting choice he's 48 years old
uh so we would be getting I'm just
imagining his most recent highper which
is Joel and they aged him up as Joel In
The Last of Us so he's younger than Joel
is on that show I believe right I might
be wrong about that I think he is I
think yeah they bumped him a bit because
it was like a big time Jump yeah but
even then he seems to me like a warrier
kind of like just between the lone
Gunslinger of the Mandalorian and Joel
like that's what people see him as I
think a lot of people forget that he was
Obin Martell Obin Martell is not he's
more of a Johnny Storm figure than a
Reed Richards is for sure but um on the
Mandalorian he has proven himself
capable of uh very technical dialogue I
think we forget like he has to like get
through a lot of like interesting so
when I think of Reed Richards he has to
be the smartest one in the room he has
to be the scientist in the room and
that's when I first heard Pedro Pascal
I'm like I almost see him more as Ben
Grim than I do uh read Richards but I
think he can do it he is a frontman he
does have star power and that's
something that they need in this role
and I think if he can be the the face of
this franchise uh which I think he can
be that's what's most important I think
he is a very versatile actor and I don't
want to pigeon hole him into like the
weary Western Gunslinger roles that he's
played recently I also something that I
really don't want to have happen as well
and this this is Hollywood and this is
like one thing I'd love to kind of be
broken down a little bit more um if he's
if he's going to be Reed Richards and
he's 48 years old I really don't want a
28y old Sue storm please I'm really over
those age
discrepancies um I don't think it's
realistic uh and I don't want to keep
perpetuating it like there's just so
many instances where there's such a huge
age gap between love interests on camera
um and I know Vanessa Kirby I think
she's around 37 um she's 35 she's 35
she's 35 so that's like that's not
ridiculous but it's still 13 years you
know um you know they didn't meet in
college
together hey it's half your age half
your age plus seven is what some people
say uh uh look don't look if you know
people in your lives viewer who have big
age gaps we're not judging we're that at
allw Norm Hollywood treats this as a
norm and that age Gap gets wider and
wider and that historically it get it's
very weird it's really weird they get
older and you stay the same age uhhuh
uhuh that's kind of the name of the game
so we're not saying that it's wrong we
know what the laws are we're just saying
Hollywood
presents this imagery as if this is
what's normal and it's never lopsided it
is never an older woman with a younger
guy unless that's the joke of it like oh
look at this cougar Samantha from Sex in
the City isn't that so risque it's never
just normal uh I know there are some
probably instances but like
statistically it's just so rare to see
it lopsided that's what we're talking
about and I'm trying to break that uh
stigma
single-handedly single-handedly M what
is going on on in your life right
now nothing nothing at all hey let's go
back to um some of the almost casting
rumors that happened apparently deadline
said earlier this week that there were
um like other people in talks but there
were other wait was that deadline or was
that someone else well our uh our
colleague Jeff Snider of uh the hot mic
podcast um he has been talking quite a
bit about these rumors and he said that
just before the SAG after strike began
over the summer that a few actors had
been screen tested for the role
including Christopher Abbott now he's
really cute he's got beautiful brown
eyes with really thick eyelashes sorry
thank you for clarifying that mod you're
welcome you made know Christopher abbit
from it comes at night in sanctuary very
talented as well as Jamie Jordan from 50
Shades of Gray and Belfast and wasn't he
in that true crime show that I saw on
Netflix that was from the UK possibly
possibly with Gillian Anderson in it now
Jamie D is good I can see yeah I can see
him being a bit of a Richard Reed but
apparently they didn't go very well
those tests yes wouldn't you haing to s
for that to get yeah you don't want look
uh and and and James Gunn has said
before uh that he doesn't like sharing
information about actor screen tests
because that's just like unfair to the
actors he could have a bad day I burst
into tears once during an audition you
can find my old screen test for new rock
stars where I decided to wear a shirt
the same colors as this backdrop and I
definitely didn't get it but like my
friends who I had recommended for the
job from The Improv Community got it
instead of me so that's how Hollywood
Works no I didn't get the job I was
deemed too ugly to be a new rockstars
host in so many way who's getting the
laugh L white L's I'm getting the Lost
laugh uh yeah but actually after those
tests maybe didn't go well they started
looking at Jake Gyllenhaal and a lot of
people were like wait he played mystery
in the MC no this is what I'm saying
like get away from that like just let
actors play different roles sure you
know Jimma Chan did it uh we're all good
with it oh yeah but it's Jimma freaking
Chan come on she's the most beautiful
woman on the planet Jake Gyllenhaal is
also quite good-look but his name is his
name is too big I just kind of think
there's enough this is like a great
opportunity to have another name at the
table you know a lot of guys will get
their acting careers like kicking off at
35 to 40 give one of those guys a chance
Hall reportedly wanted too much money
also like he's like look um one of my
ex-girlfriends just keeps writing songs
about me she hates me and now all her
fans hate
me just give the scarf back dude get
give the scarf back um and uh apparently
Jeff Snider also said that like Emma
Stone was being considered for two storm
but also would have wanted too much
money which begs the question should
Pedro Pascal be asking for more money at
this stage yeah D should be making Bank
Less work more money that's where he's
at right now if your holiday plans
include taking a winter vacation now is
the time to start brushing up on
practical phrases you'll need to get
around wherever you're headed that's
where Mand comes in mandle is one of the
top language education apps worldwide
letting you mix and match from 33 native
languages to any of 41 foreign languages
with everything from French and Spanish
to Catalan farsy and finish Mand uses
speech recognition to provide realtime
feedback on your pronunciation and all
of M's l lesons are recorded by native
speakers so you are hearing the language
as it's meant to be heard the lessons
are focused on practical content that
you'd use every day and are structured
around daily weekly and monthly quizzes
to make it easy to review and recap what
you've learned monley has over 110
million users and it's not hard to see
why mandley is currently having an
exclusive sale with a 96% discount for a
limited time offer whoa to get a
lifetime of mandley for only $89.99
click the link in the description or go
to mandley
new rock stars um I'm not wearing a new
Rockstar shirt right now I'm sorry I
just hopped off a plane but we have some
amazing new rock stars merch we got a
god of stories shirt inspired by the
Loki finale we got a great flurin shirt
inspired by the wonderful flerkens of
the Marvels it's the best way to support
the channel uh and there's lots of just
great options nerd rot. shop and don't
forget to subscribe to all three
channels in the new rock stars Network
new rock stars the break room and the
Deep di you're not going to say it it's
Christmas coming up soon if you need a
present for a nerd that's best bit it is
it really is yep now let's talk about
the rest of the Marvel first family uh
we've got some Front Runners Happening
Here I mentioned her a little bit
earlier Vanessa Kirby for Sue storm uh
if you don't know Vanessa Kirby she's
been in the U Mission Impossible movies
she's delightful she was in the crown
I'm a big fan of hers again it depends
who her Mr Reed Richards is going to be
though we got Joseph Quinn who's going
to be Johnny Storm mayhaps Joseph Quinn
from stranger things he absolutely
crushed for that one and I actually like
that casting I think that that could be
a lot of fun I want to get see him a
little bit more cheeky a little bit more
F boy uh and then eban Moss bck for Ben
Grim I don't think I'm saying his name
correctly and for that I apologize but I
had to look him up and he was in
Netflix's newly released uh Jennifer
Lawrence movie um the one where she gets
absolutely NY and he has this sort of a
bit roll as a tow truck driver oh not
just that mod he's in the bear playing
cousin so good in that show and was my
favorite thing he was my comfort food in
season two of but is he BM he yes he
could be anything that guy is like I
think top three actors working right now
he was an Andor he played like the guy
in Andor episode four and five and six
the AL Arc no it was before that it was
like the mission where they had the big
like meteor shower Mission oh was on
that crew and just fit into Star Wars
perfectly uh he was in girls he played
uh like a manic boyfriend of one of the
girls like he's been around forever oh
he was in John Adams the HB I clearly
have been following this guy for his
entire career I'm obsessed I mean I'm
not saying he's a bad actor I just don't
see him as Ben Grim oh no he can I see
him more as Uncle Ben if anything it's a
crime that they're going to be covering
up with like rock skin because he is so
good I mean he could be Johnny Storm
could be Reed Richards he could be
anybody it's clearly it's clear that
like uh Sarah Haley fin is like I'm
going to put you in somewhere in this
universe like he could be um uh Silver
Surfer he could be Doom like this guy is
so good I if we're going there are we
going to go there right now yeah let's
go there Dr Doom I have what I think
could be a great a great casting for it
I mean it was Julian McMahon in the last
fantastic fall which I think he got
underplayed in um but he's Australian so
I have to have a little bias there now
this is an actor who got done real dirty
by DC and then Netflix and I think that
he needs his come upin brilliant actor
absolutely gorgeous but we've never
really seen him as like the evil bad guy
we got a taste of it when Henry cavl was
The Witcher but I think Henry caval
could be a great Dr Doom longer hair a
little bit messed up and just
permission to get real kooky and spooky
cookie spooky hey I'll watch Henry caval
do anything in the MCU anything I think
he's this is another star who could do
it he could be Johnny Storm he could be
Reed Richards maybe not Johnny Storm
he's a little too big and old yeah he's
too RI now but um I just think that when
you remember how James gun was like um
Marvel's champion and then Marvel kind
of discarded him for a little bit and so
he went to DC and gave him his best
stuff and then Marvel's like please come
back that's what I see happening for
Henry caval you think you think think so
Marvel Studios traded James gun for
Henry caval is what it should what
should happen that's what happen hey uh
that sounds great mod too bad it's
probably gonna be Jean caros Esposito
you know it's gonna be Jean caros
Esposito like that guy he's he's in the
mix like but he's already played a
Marvel villain not Marvel but like a
Disney villain uhhuh across from Pedro
Pascal they're going to do that he's
another guy they just want to put in
everything he's so good at playing a
villain I just think
Johnny Storm we can speculate on we can
speculate on it but I guarantee you it's
gonna be like two weeks from now they'll
be like yeah it's justan Carlos espito
and it won be like okay so it's just
Mandalorian hero and villain and the
Fantastic for and it'll be like oh I
guess I could work work before if it
don't work don't fix it I have I'm not
quoting anyone I have no inside sources
I just feel like that's what they're
going to do well Jeff SNY on the hot
Mike podcast thinks that the cast is
going to be announced the first week of
December that's like three weeks time
coming up we don't have to wait for too
long we don't have to wait for too long
I think SNY also said and I heard this
somewhere that uh they're looking at
Javier BM for galatis but it would just
be like his voice and maybe some moap
stuff um I think didn't we hear Antonio
Banderas was being considered for
galatis as well I like to eat the
galaxies is that your
pce yeah uh cool sounds good I mean I I
also saw some reporting that like
because they have it like locked in with
uh was Sue Johnny and Ben and they're
all white that they needed to some
diversity but I I think Pedro Pascal
like he's not just a you know a quote
unquote diversity higher he is a star in
his own right and he can play anything
um yeah so we'll see I totally forgot
about Michael B Jordan being the last
Human Torch totally forgot about Kate
Mara totally forgot Miles Teller I
forgot I think I was supposed to I think
that's what they wanted us uh uhhuh
that's that timeline is currently being
pruned by the TVA it's just taking them
some time all I can think about is when
um you know Johnny Storm was skiing and
he um fell in the snow but because he's
the Human Torch it ended up being like a
little hot tub for him so we were
talking about Dr Doom uh in terms of
casting but let's talk about Dr Doom in
terms of like franchise building because
you know it what real news that came out
this week Destin Daniel keton has left
Avengers King Dynasty he's no longer in
it I think that they worded it like that
can I be real with you I don't think
that they're going to do it at all I
think um they've changed the finale uh
to completely step away from a Kang
Dynasty and the way that they've done it
is that Dustin Daniel keton gets his
Integrity intact and they say that he's
left it I don't think the Project's
going to exist again I don't think it's
going to exist anymore wow wow so you
think they're going to go straight to
Secret Wars MH I could see that yeah I
could see that but here's the thing I
think this there's many at the studio
who think that the franchise needs more
Avengers films not less Avengers films I
think that they're trying to I think
they did such a successful job with
building up everyone's origin story and
then having the teams you know come
together that they're holding on to the
Brilliance that that was now I know that
you and I have very different measures
of like how we appreciated the Avengers
coming together in that way um but I
think that the more that they expand and
Star Wars is going through the same
thing they were holding on to the
Skywalker Saga for so long that the more
that they ban the more they're like I
don't think it's working as much and I
think overall this is Marvel sorry this
is Disney's biggest problem they build
out the core so much that um there's not
enough to hold on to or like to to bring
the next phases or the next eras um what
am I trying to say you know there's not
enough to to make that as successful and
I think what's happening with the
Marvels with the television shows and
the other um slate that's um put out
there their brightest light was at the
beginning so I don't know
you know I think that might be accurate
but I think I want to bring it back what
we'll see I think uh they're GNA have
two Avengers movies in on the Slate I
think Young Avengers or no what I'm
thinking is it'll either be some version
of Kang Dynasty that might get renamed
if they do move away from Kang and then
we'll have Secret Wars or they'll go
straight to Secret Wars and make it a
part one in part two like kind of
infinity War part one and part two and
then in part two ended up being called
endgame but no one I don't think that
the hype for Secret Wars is going to be
there just for the name you need
to no people are [__] pumped for
storytelling to like Cliffhanger to then
solve it in a part one part two as soon
as you get Deadpool and Wolverine the
table's set for Secret Wars I think as
soon as you get X-Men on screen people
are ready there it is I think that
Fantastic 4 is going to be the Catalyst
for mutants I know that don't want to
spoil anything but there has been a hint
about mut Universe being there but I
have a feeling that Fantastic 4 maybe
it's not going to come out in time but
my theory was the importance of
Fantastic 4 this iteration was that Reed
Richard was looking into the multiversal
kind of structure the equilibrium the
the mathematics to kind of do inter
dimensional travel and I thought that it
would be the Fantastic for crew that go
into dimensionally and discover the
mutants now my favorite thing about
X-Men especially in the ' 90s cartoon
was that opening shot where you have two
sets of mutants going for it but then
you realize that over the course of
X-Men that those mutants have to then
team up because humanity is so scared of
them I think it'd be really cool if this
world's versions of a superhero is that
world's version of a mutant um and it's
both sides thinking the others the
threat and then you realize the threat
is anyone who doesn't have superpowers
which is kind of the story of gen V but
I'd like it to be Reed Richards that
kind of discovers the interdimensional
travel is what I'm trying to say see I
think it's already kind of been
discovered I think Reed Richards is just
going to give us a language for it uh I
think mutants I don't know if Marvel can
wait for a Fantastic Four movie I mean
that we've already seen beasts we've
seen Charles Xavier we're going to see
Wolverine before that and kamalak Khan's
a mutant I think Deadpool's going to
just spill mutants into the multiversal
oh my gosh I want like an Acme button
that he's like what is this boom and
that's how it happens that's what I
would love hey it's Deadpool it's
possible uh I yeah I think Reed's going
to give us like uh a glossery of terms
for how this all works which a version
of Reed has already done in Multiverse
of Madness we'll get that in Fantastic 4
I think you're right mod I could imagine
the studio dissolving whatever plans
they had for for Kang Dynasty but I
think they'll jump straight to Secret
Wars because I think somewhere I think
might be feige is just saying well we
can't have mutants on the ground in the
MCU until we've had the secret Wars
event and there's probably some people
Marvel Studios are like well then we
need to get to Secret Wars faster so
that we can just have like a storm
miniseries we can have our jilee
miniseries I think they need to get to
Secret Wars faster because now that Loki
season 2 is done and it doesn't look
like there's going to be a season three
they need the next big thing at the
moment it is Deadpool but like oo that
next year is looking empty I a lot of
stuff is being configured and I think
that's why everything was delayed we
still have Deadpool in place CU
Deadpool's going to be fine either way
but I think they're going to take these
months to reconfigure the game plan they
may already have the new game plan and
it wouldn't surprise me if Dr Doom is at
the center of it we'll find out in the
next few days I mean they're going to
blame it on the
strike and I think there is a big you
know there is effects from the strike
happening but I think that they also
thought that their these last this last
phase would have gone Gang
Busters and there's been some hits but
there's been some misses sure sure and
there's only been misses because they
just just green lit everything because
the directive from chaik was we need
streaming money money money oh yeah yeah
that too Disney plus agree um Robert
Kirkman apparently let something slip oh
yeah tell us about that Robert Kirkman
while promoting Invincible uh starring
Stephen Yun as Mark Grayson Invincible
just kind of blabbed that Stephen yun's
gonna be playing senty in an upcoming
Thunderbolts film now this was
speculated for months and months and
months that Stephen y's going to be
playing but was never confirmed but he
had this coming from a director who's
worked with him and his friend uh so
does this make Kirkman a scooper I hope
so is Robert Kirkman my time to shine
hello is he can we get some toast I
think I don't get that reference oh my
you know what I hope you never do
understand that reference I hope you can
just stay out of this scary scary world
of online scoopers it's it's a dangerous
Wild West down here in the trenches mod
and you don't need to be part of it as
an entertainment reporter my person
personal slogan is I'm not in the
business of ruining lives I like that
that's a have so many things that I've
heard and they have firsthand knowledge
of and I'm just like nope I'd hate it to
be done to me I'm not going to do it to
someone else I like that let's get that
heat check though yeah heat check you
know what I'm feeling good I'm feeling
good uh I think the you know some people
are you know clutching their pearls as
we all expected about the box office
performance of mar the Marvels but uh I
think it's G to be fine I think soon
they're going to announce this lineup it
may even be announced by the time you're
watching this and then everyone's going
to be excited for the future of Marvel I
like I'm totally okay with Pedro Pascal
just because I know he is a great actor
and whatever they need Reed Richards to
be I think he can rise to the occasion
it is so funny that I could see Pedro as
Ben as
Johnny hell put a wig on him as Sue yeah
like he has that versatility which is
great um but I'd like to hear from
everyone in the comments can you Fan
cast your Fantastic Four who do you see
as Reed Richards Sue storm who are you
seeing as Johnny Storm who are you
seeing as Ben Grim I'd love to get your
fan casts happening in that chat it's
not locked in yet it ain't over till
it's over so I want to hear from you um
what you think with that one and thanks
so much for watching yeah we'll leave it
there for this episode of the sneak peek
be sure to follow modmod Garrett you can
follow me at eaos follow new rock stars
on all socials And subscribe to all
three of our channels and we'll see you
next week thanks for joining me for this
chat mod it's been great thank you for
having me bye-bye bye-bye
[Music]
everybody